and on the mount for the cubs a 28 year
old change-up specialist zach davies tim
anderson leading it off first pitch
swing and a drive out into right well
hit it's gonna go
one pitch one run sox lead one zip
one out one in one on for the left
fielder eloy jimenez
[Applause]
a swing and a drive well hit out to
center field ortega's back still in
chase mode and he looks up and it's gone
three nothing white socks this is a
massive monster shot here's andrew
vaughn he's hitting 360 over his last 16
games
fawn sends the ball down to left center
field that ball is crushed and that
one's gone oh my goodness a three homer
inning to start the night
hard throwing 25 year old right hander
and former cub property dylan cease
the kick and the o2 called strike three
three consecutive sliders
and duffy out for looking
[Applause]
and contreras is unable to hold off as
swinging to miss to retire the side in
the first
[Applause]
and anderson's got his second base hit
of the game
pretty good for a guy who three hours
ago thought he wasn't in the lineup
as angle strikes out for round number
two
abreu lines that into left
two out single first and second with two
gun in the second inning so here's
elohimenas now
[Applause]
and there's one up the line on the
ground that'll do some damage anderson's
being waved around to score half having
trouble with it and here comes zabrayu
right behind him it's a two-run double
for eloy jimenez and the start of a
monster night for the white sox left
fielder the sox lead seven nothing
and a called strike three taken by
moncada three strikeouts in the inning
but two more runs for the white sox
swing and a miss on a pitch in the dirt
that strike three and with a man at
first
in less than two outs bodhi is
automatically called out number three
for dylan
and frank schwendell is going to come up
and pinch it or zach davies here in the
second inning
1-2 to schwendell bounced up the middle
and through it's going to be a two-run
single for the pitch hitter that puts
the cubbies on the board seven to two
cubs get on the board clutch pinch hit
two-run single right up the middle by
frank schwendell
two balls and two strikes
and duffy's rung up slipped the fastball
past him at 98 miles an hour
the cubs do rally for a pair
play two complete seven to two white sox
falling two strikes from the reliever
jake jewel to sebby zavala
and jewel strikes him out so nothing
comes at the lead off walk
two one line to deep left field
backwards jimenez that ball is going to
be off the top of the wall contreras
going for two the throw to second not in
time it's a double for wilson contreras
counts two balls and two strikes to
wisdom and a call strike three dikeman
the left-handed batter steps in
dikeman fades a fly ball the other way
that's going to drop in for a knock and
it's going to score contreras
cubs continue to chip away on a one-time
7-0 deficit it's now 7-3 white sox
[Applause]
janeshway checks and that's going to be
strike three tried to hold up on a
fastball couldn't do it
matt duffy batting with two gun and the
base is empty
we thought we had that out but people
are going to have to go to youtube for
it and a called strike three
[Applause]
here's eloy what a knight a homer a
double he's driven in four
and loy jimenez with another mighty
blast this one the other way an opposite
field homer and for jimenez his second
of the night eight three pale hoes
here's the pitch
swing and a miss right three
cease has eight strikeouts
contreras swings and misses he strikes
out
nine for cease
most k's on the breaking ball fourth
highest total in the game
and it's going up on his 10th of the
night
[Applause]
now the 2-2 swing and a miss
lamb is out on strikes
three two
swing and a miss strike three good job
by michael rucker a one two three inning
we go to the bottom of the six
white sox eight
cubs three
and the one two swing and a foul tip for
strike three that's 11 strikeouts ceased
with 10 lopez with one
that's out to right field another
challenge for vaughn who is up to the
task another good play by vaughn
in right field
[Applause]
swing in the miss will retire the side
torino strikes out nothing in the cubs
half of the sixth
and here's andrew vaughn once again he
has homered
and walk tonight
driven into right base hit engel scores
moncotta to second nine to three
bonds got three rbis tonight two hits
he's been on three times
[Applause]
anderson sends that one well head out to
right field and it
right against the base of the ivy
covered wall anderson wheeling into
second part of a big night for the white
sox shortstop
and a called strike three taken by engel
that gets ryan out of any further
difficulty
swing and a miss strike three
there's a late swing by alcantara and
the cubs are down to their final out
tonight
and it has been a white sox story on the
north side of chicago this weekend the
sox for just the third time in franchise
history sweep a three-game series across
town